[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships our goal here is to
completely indoctrinate
you into a whole new way of thinking
called common freaking sense we want you
to join the cult drink the Kool-Aid or
whatever other negative crap you've
heard jump in we'll help you it's what
we're here for Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality is my co-host today and of
course the phone number here is
5225 you have stepped Square in the
middle of a baby steps Millionaire's
theme hour what that means is we're
going to take questions from
millionaires this hour only and we
always have to help folks with that
because people are apparently confused
they took uh economics from their Carl
Marx indoctrinated college professor and
so we have to explain to them how this
wealth thing works uh here's the way it
works net worth is how you become a
millionaire it's not your income you can
make a million dollars a year and not be
a millionaire a millionaire by
definition it is an accounting
definition it is not you don't get to
make up your own definition this is the
only definition is what you own minus
what you owe assets minus liabilities
equals your net worth when that number
is greater than a million dollars you
are a millionaire well it I don't feel I
don't care how you feel it's not a
feeling it's a math entry I I don't
think anybody ought have that kind of
money it's not a moral construct a
million dollars is not enough it's not
an economics lesson it's a
number called net worth when you reach
that you are by definition a millionaire
now we can discuss the other parts of
that if you want but in the meantime
let's talk to people who actually
achieve the Milestone of becoming a real
millionaire because people out there
inquiring minds can want to know they do
they do phone number 8825 5225 we're
going to talk to real millionaires not
your broke brother-in-law who votes
wrong we're going to talk to people who
really did this stuff Mike is in
Woodstock Georgia Mike what is your net
worth 11 million boom wow and uh give me
a little breakdown on that
dude so I've got about five million in
real estate um my split of the business
I own is about 5 million right now
roughly and then I've probably got
another million in rough assets between
cash and uh I don't really do stocks or
anything so that's the rough numbers
there very cool all right how how old
are you 28 holy wow wow and how much of
this did you
inherit none zero you did this from
Nothing by 28 years old yes sir whoa
okay so what's been your range of income
since you started working to your best
year it's kind of hard to judge but I
would say starting at 18 was probably my
lowest year around
8,000 and then my best year would
probably have been last year was a
little over 2 million okay okay good
Lord what do you
do I own a uh Property Restoration
company oh specializing in water damage
mold remediation fire damage
construction a lot of it too yeah a lot
of it we have two locations so wow you
guys are doing some volume good good for
you wow so are you a college graduate
I'm not I'm a Dropout loud and proud hey
I'm with you I'm with you I'm with you
okay so you were in college though what
were you
studying I was studying whatever made my
mama
happy she was first to graduate of our
family so and now Mama's not happy
you're just highly successful all oh
well we're we're past that now but was
multiple years of uh you're not going to
make it I love it okay so what was uh
what was your GPA do you remember in
high school or in
college it was always above a 3.0 I'd
say average is about 3.5 okay all right
very good all right cool floating
floating by so there's an 18-year-old
out there listening that shows us over
Tik Tok today um and so he might
actually get some real information from
you cuz you actually did this from 18 to
28 and 10 years went from $80,000 to $2
million income with an $1 million net
worth uh removing mold and mildew and
water damage and doing a lot of
insurance work I suspect on volume what
do you tell that 18-year-old the secret
to your net worth is where did it come
from well it came from my stepdad who is
actually a gigantic fan of you and he he
kind of put this in me at a young age
and so when I hit my successes um I I my
big Focus was I don't know how long this
is going to last and I I need to pay off
debt I need to get ahead I need to make
sure that I set myself up for the future
and it's addicting and it's just like
you talk about and when you knock it out
and you put it behind you um it it
really allows you to do a lot more
investment type things like I've been
able to do with real estate um but I
would say the biggest thing is is you
don't have to have a college degree you
got to have a work ethic and you need to
make good choices choices that will help
you in the future not punish you right
now or punish you later what kind of
good choices what does that mean so when
I started my business and took a risk um
I took just enough money to pay my bills
and pay my mortgage and my car paying
payment and all the normal stuff okay so
choices were your good choice was you
didn't consume everything you made you
plowed it back in immediately and I got
my first distribution and I put it all
down on my house the house that I bought
when I was 18 19 and I was able to have
it paid off by the time I was 23 years
old 24 years old fantastic I want to ask
a question on choices you're 3.5 in high
school so I mean you've got obviously
intelligence you didn't slack off but
dropped out of college at what point did
you realize that you wanted to do the
work you're doing now and did that play
into you dropping out it certainly
played it certainly played into dropping
out um I
realized I had a good gig coming out of
high school I started at the very bottom
at a Restoration company at 16 years old
um and I found it fascinating seemed
like the owners did really well and I
wanted to be in that position and so I
worked my way up to project manager
general manager vice president so on and
so forth and um I was doing really well
so I kind of told my mom you know I'm
doing great I I want to jump jump out
and it was the greatest decision I ever
made if I wouldn't have had that there I
may not have taken that risk but it was
a calculated risk for sure do you do you
love what you do what kind of emotion
would you attach to your
work I love what I do um and it it
consumes a lot of my life my biggest
struggle is making sure that I have a
work life balance because I got a lot of
people that look up to me to lead this
ship and so I have to be good every day
and so that's a good pressure that keeps
me going but I very much enjoy helping
people and I very much enjoy being able
to take care of the ones that that
support me and support this business Wow
Mike you're an American hero small
business is the backbone of America 28
years old with an $1 million net worth
that's fascinating he's exhibit a the
study the largest study of net worth
millionaires ever done by Ramsey
solution said that 96% of these kind of
people like Mike love their work and he
loves what he's doing for people I hate
my job I hate my boss I hate my company
is not a formula to wealth that's right
hello this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality number
one best-selling author of the book
paycheck to purpose the career expert
around the uh Ramsey personality Bunch
he's my co-host today this is a baby
steps millionaires theme hour we're
talking to real millionaires not broke
people with an opinion on Tik Tok real
millionaires what did you do who are you
we want to learn about you so we can be
one of you that is what America is
saying to you if you're a real
millionaire call us at trip8 825
5225 Marsha's in Charlotte North
Carolina hey Marsha welcome to a baby
steps millionaire seam hour what's your
net worth hi Dave and Ken it's so nice
to talk to you those my net worth is
1.29 million good for you and give me a
little breakdown on that sure I've got
$740,000 in retirement between 401k and
a Roth IRA Roth IRA
$350,000 in equity in my house and the
balance is made up of just liquid cash
and other non-retirement
Investments good for you well done how
old are you I just turned 45 last month
cool and how much of this did you
inherit well the only thing I've
inherited so far is just some knowledge
and good oldfashioned walking around
since but there's been no money no money
okay that that's well you got you do
have an advantage just the same uh
because if you got walking around sense
it's more than most people got so there
you go this is true yeah so uh your
range of income your best working Year
to your worst working
year yeah when I first came out of
college my first big girl job was making
$331,000 a year and I'm currently making
between 165 and $70,000 depending on how
bonuses and profit sharing works out
what do you do what's your career so I
am an insurance claims professional I
work in a technical space for a
commercially Commercial Property and
Casualty insur and I'm currently uh in a
leadership role um leading other claims
professionals four-year
degree yes uh a fouryear degree in
finance in finance okay and your GPA
when you were in school it was probably
about a 3.0 or a 3.1 I've kind of put
that behind me Dave yeah yeah I'm I I
have tried to forget mine cuz it's a
2.97 and I'm really pissed off about
that 3100s of a point still 40 years
later but I think it had something to do
with beer I don't know but the um anyway
yeah so way to go way to go you're
single it sounds like I am I've never
married and never had any kids I am a
one woman band da I love it good for you
well done what do you tell a young
version of you 25 years old that's
listening can she do it in America today
and if she can what should she do if she
wants to be you yes she Absol she
absolutely can if she wants it to happen
if you want it to happen you can um I
think the one of the biggest things is
finding discipline that was something
that was difficult for me in my early
20s um you know F find who who do you
want to be decide who you want to be and
follow a proven plan and a process to
get there also finding contentment just
enjoying and being happy with what you
have you don't have to buy all the big
Happy Shiny things those will come in
time but just learn contentment with
what you have and also I think a big
thing too is discernment learning
discernment with the company you keep
you are who you hang around with so if
you want to be a fool hang out with
fools if you want to be successful in
life and live a rewarding life find
those that are successful and have a
rich rewarding life and keep company
with those
people wow that's really deep you know
uh I think a lot of people listening in
are wondering what did you do and to to
be intentional in that last statement to
to put yourself around the right people
who were you seeking out along your way
well I wanted to find people that lived
a life that I aspired to have I mean not
unlike a lot of young 20 people uh
single people I like to go out and have
a good time so I was running with a
crowd that was just living daytoday
having a good time I decided this is not
who I want to be when I grow up so I
need to find other people so I sought
out people who were successful in life
not only with wealth but had fulfilling
Liv and decided that I want to model
myself after them see what they're doing
um and be that wow what's the biggest
money mistake you've ever
made oh man how can I count the ways so
I would say the biggest one was probably
when I purch purchased my first home it
was I think around 2006 or 2007 I was
not financially prepared for it at all I
didn't have any money I had debt so I
took out one of those subprime loans in
80 20% so basically yeah the second High
interest um the the 20% loan was
variable so when interest rates went up
um but I fought through that I paid it
all off myself probably another big
mistake I made was um purchas in a new
car um but you live you learn and I
think part of life is learning Grace too
give yourself grace allow yourself to
make a mistake just don't make that same
mistake twice there you go I like that
try not to compound the dumb ones yeah I
love it well done well done hero proud
of you Melanie is in Las Vegas Melanie
what's your net
worth hi Dave absolute honor to talk to
you um my net worth right now is uh 1.8
cool give me a little breakdown by
category on that uh it's a mix of uh
retirement accounts between my husband
and I um would be how much uh retirement
accounts oh goodness uh mine I actually
break it down every six months uh mine
uh in July was about 307,000 U my
husband's is about 266,000 okay so about
five about 600 between those two all
right what's the other
1.3 um we have uh College accounts for
our kids about 180,000 and 529s for them
um we have property uh valued about
900,000 um so that's our main house and
then we have a rental property as well
and then between bank accounts and other
taxable uh Investments it's about
200,000 okay very good how old are you
I'm 44 good for you okay and how much of
this did you guys
inherit so um we actually own a business
on the side which I don't count in my uh
in my net worth currently um but that
the money that we used to open that was
inherited for my mother-in-law how
much I you know I don't know it's a how
much did you inherit oh um it was about
200,000 okay all right so that helped
you guys in this net worth although that
particular use of that 200 is not
calculated in this 1.8 no sir because I
don't know exactly how much the business
is actually worth gotcha okay and your
best year of income and your worst year
of income since you started
adulting uh well I am a service member
so my worst year of income was when I
first came in about 25 years ago so
maybe 30,000 a year if that all right uh
and I would say the best is now um
between my husband and I we make about
uh 250 good for you good for you and
which branch do you serve in uh the Air
Force thank you thank you for your
service oh thank you it's my pleasure uh
a have uh you got a four-year degree uh
I we do my husband and I both have NBAs
okay and what was your GPA in your NBA
program uh
mine was probably about a 3.6 my husband
probably about a 4.0 okay very good well
done well done thank you um what's the
biggest mistake you ever made with money
the dumbest thing you ever did so I
actually have uh two things actually one
was really big one was really small when
my husband and I were first starting out
we were first married we didn't have a
lot of money and we had saved maybe
$1,000 which was huge to me uh and we
got taken by a door too encyclopedia
salesman and uh we ended up paying
$1,500 for a set of encyclopedias which
I have had for 25 you're not old enough
to buy a door too encyclopedias you must
have been
12 you wouldn't think so but lot of
people don't even know what that
is wow I still have them and made many
mov with us so yes the other money
mistake was um we purchased a home in
California while we when we were
stationed there and we had some I
wouldn't say it was bad advice but we
trusted some folks that were older and
had money and we thought they were smart
with money and they told us to kind of
weather the storm we bought our house in
California in about 2004 and we moved
from California to um Las Vegas in 2007
so it was about that you know right
around the market crash um and we should
have just sold the property but we we
decided to weather the storm and we held
on the property for about a decade and
we took a huge loss on it uh over the
years we couldn't rent it for what the
mortgage was ouch that hurts bad real
estate deal number one mistake good job
Melanie way to go hero Ken Coleman Dave
Ramsey it's a baby steps millionaires
theme
[Music]
[Applause]
hour
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more Ken Coleman Ramsey personal it is
my co-host today this is a baby steps
millionaires theme hour we started doing
these theme hours which led to a
research project the largest research
project ever done on millionaires in
North America we ended up studying with
airtight controlled research technique
over
10,167 millionaires we came to some very
interesting conclusions from that
research it informed us some things we
thought we knew that we didn't and uh
really had some numbers that were kind
of mind-blowing when we got into it we
did that and we started this hour
because I kept hearing from all the Hope
Stealers the angry leftists that America
is dead you can't become a millionaire
in America today it's
impossible uh you know we we must have
Anarchy we must have KL Marx sitting on
the throne of communism because the
little man just can't get ahead all
millionaires today in America have
inherited their money you've heard that
right all millionaires have some kind of
privilege you've heard that right and
it's basically victim speak from
hopeless people and it's really in one
sense it's angering but another because
it's defeating other people with hope
but uh in the other sense it is um it's
sad it's pitiful to live a life that
thinks you're stuck and you can't win no
matter what you do people like me
we can't get
ahead the neighborhood I grew up in
you're always going to have a car
payment you can't be a student without a
student
loan Eeyore is my spirit
animal I mean you know how these people
sound none of them sound excited there's
never any crispness or Sparkle or
passion in their voice it's always like
somebody's dragging them around behind a
car when you're talking to them oh it's
bad
and all the rich people and all the
people in the other area of the country
and all the people that are a different
color and all the people that are a
different sex and all the people oh shut
up really that's just wrong and the data
proves it's wrong that's why we started
doing these to to introduce you to real
millionaires uh because they're from
every area of the country every age
group every level of Education every
color every background cinjun to
Hillbillies to
African-Americans to
um Chinese immigrants I don't care you
just name whatever group you want to
name we find millionaires in them and we
find victims in them and we find
hopeless people in them you know it's
like I I I never forget Ken the one that
the first time I blew my mind when I
first started doing this years ago I got
a speaking gig in New York City and I
had never spoken I mean I primarily
spoken around the South so pretty much
you know uh Gomer pow goes to New York
to speak right and so sh you know and
it's like well goly would you look
at all them people and so I go up to New
York and I I'm in this huge ballroom and
I speak to this group of about 2,000
people and I had books and I'm signing
books at the end and it looked like the
United Nations I mean you've got and of
course New York City is a Melting Pot
you got everything right it looked like
any possible uh background or mix of
backgrounds right and so I'm signing
books and I'll never forget this lady
came up to me she goes you don't you
don't understand what I don't understand
she said well you know the people like
me we we all all my people buy new cars
and I'm like uh that's like everybody
what are you and she said I'm Puerto
Rican I'm like it's not a Puerto Rican
disease
baby that's not unique to Puerto Ricans
it's like but she had figured out that
Puerto Ricans all had to have new cars
in her mind because she was Puerto Rican
isn't it funny how we do that stuff and
that's why we do this hour is to defeat
the kind of Mythology the tapes that we
play in our heads that give us an excuse
to not go leave the cave kill something
drag it home and freaking
win no excuses
no Kwan is with us Kwan is in Houston
Texas hey Kwan what is your net worth uh
right around 2.1 good for you okay and
give me a little breakdown by category
how much retirement how much house and
so on uh retirement probably 650 uh
mutual funds and other Investments
outside of retirement probably
600 uh about 60 and 529 for my kids uh
real estate right about
700 um and then another 70 or so um in
Angel Investing cool how old are you I'm
40 good for you and how much of this did
you inherit zero zero and your best
working year income and worst working
year income uh best uh right around 300
um then worse uh was when I first
started out of college about 32k okay
cool what do you do for a living I'm a
Solutions architect okay a what kind of
architect Solutions Solutions AR like as
in digital yes as in digital dig space
all right cool uh you got a four-year
degree I do in uh in what information
systems or something what yep in
Information Systems got it okay and
you're uh
GPA uh I think it was like 2.5 okay all
right good for you all right cool uh it
can this still be done the uh
20-year-old version of you uh you know
poking around on the whole digital space
lots of opportunity there can they
become worth 2.1 by the time they're 40
or is America dead absolutely absolutely
they can um probably even faster um
there's so many opportunities out there
for sure I agree with that uh what would
you tell them the secret is
um just really having a plan um
budgeting um and understanding where you
want to go and driving towards those
goals yeah I'm curious was there a fast
forward button at any point for you in
this
journey um I think the only fast forward
um thing was anytime I did get a bonus I
never spent it I just Ed it as
opportunity to invest
wow how many times would you say you did
that over your career got the bonus and
then compounded it by investing it uh I
probably done that over the last 10 to
12 years for sure wow that adds up quick
doesn't it for sure that's kind of like
living on what you make and throwing the
bonus to the gravy yep yeah that's I
like that plan that alone will stack up
cash obviously 2.1 million by the time
you're 40 congratulations man so did you
grow up around wealthy people we were
just talking about the different people
groups what would your what would your
tribe
be uh probably lower middle class okay
okay and what would you am curious sorry
Dave uh what what would you say
contributed to the mentality that
changed you to be able to do this you
broke your family tree man
yeah um I think what contributed to it
is just understanding that um and
thinking and learning about money in a
new way um I guess it was always just an
interest of mine but just taking the
time to learn about it to understand how
it works works and how it grows um
really became an interest of mine so I
dug deep into it and and started doing
everything that I needed to do to make
that possible yeah and it's not really a
big mystery once you dig into it right
very true yeah sadly it's very basic
yeah hey man good job I'm proud of you
hero excellent excellent job Robert is
in Tulsa Oklahoma Robert you're net
worth 1.4 million good for you sir give
me a little breakdown by category please
so retirement 724 ,000 houses worth
350,000 have non-retirement Investments
of
172,000 I have a health savings accounts
got
48,000 about uh 20,000 in cash and Dave
I've got about 140,000 of things with
wheels tires Motors and Jet
drives nice he's a gadget guy I like him
all right how old are you Robert 59 good
for you and how much of this did you
inherit well in 20 U 21 my mom passed
away and our share was about 300,000
okay but I had just barely become a
millionaire at that time so you were
already a millionaire before you got
this yep so I don't let me put words in
your mouth but I think I hear you saying
you're not you did not become a
millionaire because of inherited money
correct it enhanced the program after
you were already there yeah absolutely
you're the man you're the man can it
still be done Robert
absolutely just got to follow the baby
steps what's your career your means I'm
a doctor I'm a psychiatrist a
psychiatrist all right obviously that's
your degree what was your uh what was
your
GPA well Dave undergraduate not all
doctors are 4.0 it was
2.0 okay I'm sorry 2.8 2.8 2.8 all right
2.8 y you're right there with me brother
right there with me I love it
congratulations sir proud of you hero
another millionaire in the books this is
a baby steps milliona theme hour on the
Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks Dr John delone here with
some great news you get to choose
whatever you do good or bad moving
forward the choice is yours and when
you're intentional about making good
choices over time they become healthy
habits like choosing to slow down and
make time for a daily practice of prayer
and meditation one thing that has helped
me with a daily practice of meditation
and prayer is hallow hallow is the
number one Prayer app in the world and
they're giving you 3 months free to get
started that's 3 months free to
prioritize your mental health and be
intentional about finding peace through
calming music prayers meditation and
more and hallow isn't just Catholic you
can tailor the content towards your
faith tradition if you don't have a
faith tradition this is a great place to
learn more about it from scripture
readings and prayers to journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice
mindfulness build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and choose
peace remember hallow is giving you 90
days free imagine the peaceful habits
you can establish in 90 days go to
hall.com Ramsey today and follow the
simple prompts to start your free 90-day
trial that's hall.com
[Music]
Ramsey so baby steps millionaires theme
hour Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is
my co-host
uh spoiler alert guys the research on
millionaires the airtight research the
methodology was so pure and so good on
this research that if you disagree with
the conclusions of the research you're
what's known as
wrong okay in other words these are
facts databased facts they're not
feelings from your KL Marx induced
college
professor okay these are actual
facts
79% of of America's millionaires
inherited precisely
zero 5% of America's millionaires
inherited a very small amount like
$5,000 from
Grandmother but not enough to make them
mathematically a millionaire it was an
insignificant small amount but they did
technically get an
inheritance another 5% inherited money
that was substantial like that last
caller or caller before no the last
caller uh after they were already
millionaires so did not become
millionaires because of inherited money
but enhanced their wealth after they
were already millionaires so let me help
you with that
790 five small five after 79 + 5 + 5 is
89% that's nine out of
10 of the current approximately 15
million millionaires in North America
became millionaires not because of
inherited
money do not let people tell that lie in
your presence because when they tell
that lie they are spreading hopelessness
they are stealing Hope from
people because if you know that nine out
of 10 of America's millionaires started
with
nothing and became millionaires not
because of inherited money that should
give you hope that you too can do
this then the only question is how did
they do it what are the best practices
well a lot of them followed the baby
steps these days I've been teaching this
stuff 30 years I mean 10 million people
have been through Financial Peace
University you'd think a few of them
would get it and turn out to be
millionaires well a bunch of them got it
and turned out to be millionaires I also
want to mentioned that 96% of net worth
millionaires enjoy their work they're
not quiet quitters Dave and I had Tim
Smith who did let our research pull some
more data for me of the
96% uh so that's only 4% didn't enjoy
their work the 96% actually had a higher
net worth to the tune of 58% higher net
worth than those in that 4% who didn't
enjoy their work oh he pared the pared
the data out wow even more what tells me
that doing something you enjoy is the
key to working harder and longer in that
sacrificial time more creatively you're
getting promoted more you're putting
your best output out which means you're
getting rewarded for the output so we
don't want to miss that side of it the
baby steps huge chunk living on less
than you make the discipline piece but
you have greater discipline when you
actually enjoy showing up and you also
get better results when you enjoy it all
we also found okay what are the top 10
careers fields that people picked out uh
number one engineer at the break we met
a baby step Millionaire's engineer he's
baby step millionaire met him at the
break at the commercial break just a
minute ago sitting here in the lobby
engineer 45 years old okay um that's it
I mean number two accountant number
three
teacher yeah I don't agree with that I
don't care if you agree with it you're
wrong the number three most
occurring career field was teacher
number four business executive whatever
that means could mean anything and
number five was attorney yep Doctors
medical doctors didn't even make the top
five what do all five of those people
have in common it took us a while to
figure this one out they all are
processed people they have to follow a
series of principles if you're an
engineer and you don't follow the
principles the bridge falls down if
you're an accountant you don't get to be
creative there's accounting principles
you follow those
Creative Accounting is called
embezzlement you go to jail okay you
don't get to be creative with your
accounting teachers follow a system a
lesson plan a series of testing to
create the desired outcome business
Executives obviously following best
practices attorneys you got one way you
can conduct yourself in front of your
honor the judge or he'll put your butt
in jail for contempt you don't get to
make up stuff in the courtroom there's a
process that the law requires you abide
to or you lose the
case these are processed people and so
when it came to money they found a
process and they submitted themselves to
that process they didn't try to go well
I don't know if I agree with that I'm 18
years old and I watched a tick tock
video well don't be stupid okay don't be
stupid it'll cause you to be broke
instead you go I'm going to figure out
what the freaking process is and I'm
going to follow it and that's what
causes people to be millionaires yeah
and they do it over and over and over
today we've got a Property Restoration
guy a big U entrepreneur guy insurance
claims process Air Force try flying a
plane different than you're supposed to
fly it it's called crashing right um a
digital guy I mean Information Systems
guy you know syntax when you start
writing code you got one slash out of
place the whole thing B buggers up
doesn't work it has to have it perfect
there you have to follow process right
same thing all the way down the dad gum
list right and today is today's the
examples followed it and we didn't set
these calls up we just put it out there
if you want to call in if you won the
lottery we'll put you on here but you're
not normal as millionaires go If you
inherited $10 million and your uncle
owns a hotel chain that's great uh but
but you're not normal we'll put you on
here because we want to hear your story
all right let's get one more in before
we run out of time this hour Timothy's
in Phoenix Timothy what's your net worth
hey Dave and Ken uh my net worth is 1.1
million good for you and give me a
little breakdown by category retirement
house so on yeah so we have about 400k
in a house uh we have about 600k in um
retirement Investments about 50k in
stock options uh another 60k in
529 and then around um 40K in savings
and then unfortunately as I'm in school
right now about 29k in debt how old are
you I am 38 good and um how much of this
did you
inherit H I wish I did but nope nothing
at all nothing okay your best working
year or your worst working year income
best best work worst working year was
probably about 25k I was getting out of
school between my when I got married my
wife and I I think the best uh was about
270 but we averaged about I'd say about
160 throughout our our marriage so far
and what's your
career uh I'm a nurse um and I'm in the
uh Army Reserve ah thanks for your
service your obviously your degrees
nursing and what was your
GPA it was a whopping 3.0 okay cool cool
yeah way to go man congratulations can
this still be done to a 38-year-old
you're a 38-year-old you're talking to
an 18-year-old 20 years younger than you
that's thinking about being a nurse can
they be a millionaire oh oh absolutely
absolutely you know um for me what we
did is it was it was simple first we my
family never talked about money and so
what I did is I realized hey I want to
learn about this so I educated myself
that's something anybody can do your
books help tremendously in that um then
I worked with my wife you know we're a
team and then we created goals and we
prioritized the things that were
important for our marriage in our life
and once you create a goal you just back
plan and you realize that just by doing
the same thing consistently that you've
planned out all of a sudden and you're a
millionaire or you've accomplished some
other goal in your life that's important
so it's it's 100% doable um it just
takes those elements absolutely way to
go Timothy proud of you hero so Ken um
nobody inherited money no nobody became
a millionaire because of inherited money
uh nobody had a
4.0 uh one husband did but not wasn't on
the phone uh the gpas were all right
around three mhm uh which is typical we
find that uh you don't have to be a
genius To Be A Millionaire you do have
to have some brain matter like we don't
get 1.5 GPA okay uh but the a lot of 3.0
31s 2.97 like mine quick CL on this Dave
uh what we heard the theme this hour was
they learned about money yeah they
figured the process out and you were
talking a lot about processed people I
want to make this point to all my
nonprocessed brothers and sisters that
are listening and watching you don't
have to be processed To Be A Millionaire
but you can follow our process that's
where we come in the baby steps is the
process to become a baby steps
millionaire we're here to help you so
don't freak out follow the
[Music]
plan hey it's Ken if you love the show
and want a deeper dive on your money
Journey we have a Weekly Newsletter that
gives you trending and helpful articles
and tips on following the ramsy way go
to ramsy solutions.com today to sign up
for our newsletter again that's ramsy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
[Music]
Newsletter live from the headquarters of
Ramsey Solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people build wealth do
work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Ken Coleman host
of the Ken Coleman show number one
bestselling author of the book paycheck
to purpose our Ramsey personality that
works the most on careers and jobs is my
co-host today we're going to talk to you
about your life the phone number is
5225 Caleb is in Richland Washington hi
Caleb welcome to the Ramsey show Hello
thank you guys for taking my call today
sure what's up all right so me and my
wife are 22 years old um we're gonna
have a baby next year in the end of
March
congratulations thank you very much
we're going to move to Tennessee next
year in the beginning of July um I'm a
I'm currently a route service
representative um and my wife is an
office coordinator our income right now
is about 75 and once we move to
Tennessee if I stick with the company
our income will go down to about
36 I also do online fitness coaching on
the side um I would like to have that as
my full-time career um but I'm not sure
if I should continue doing that whenever
I move to Tennessee still do my
full-time job and hope that it works out
and turns into something that will
provide for my family or if I should
switch careers go to college and um find
something different how much how much
money are you making right now in the
online coaching
business I'm about $200 a month so still
currently in the beginning stages of it
you say how long you been doing
it um since the beginning of this year
okay so I wouldn't even call I'm gonna
be very kind but I want to be realistic
I mean you've got a lot to learn before
we can even begin to have a serious
mental conversation of okay what must be
true for me to go full-time into this
you got to keep testing this andig you
could deliver pizzas two nights a month
and beat this yeah this is this is not a
business right now this is something
you've tried and it's not working so let
me step out of this for a moment and say
anytime you got a side gig and you're
wondering what do I do uh or when should
I move from full-time job to side gig
it's when the side gig is paying you the
same amount of money or pretty darn
close to the same amount of money as the
full-time gig and I like to see three to
six months of salary inside gig bank
account now that's just my starter
advice of that what must be true for you
to move into this online fitness
coaching but uh you've got a lot of work
to do and and so I'm scared about you
going backwards in Tennessee why C why
are you coming to Tennessee and taking a
back moving
backwards um so if I if I were to stay
in the company um they pay less than
what I'm making here so it's strictly
based on location I can make commission
um but and you're you're running a out
you said correct yes for who what do you
do for unifer so we go to companies and
um provide them with mats and uniforms
and uh cleaning products yeah okay all
right so so you have an entry-level bad
job and when you move to Tennessee it
pays even less correct yeah okay all
right I don't have any college
experience either why are we moving to
Tennessee um to go with family basically
to go with
family yeah so uh my wife's sister and
brother-in-law are already over there
and her whole family including us are
kind of doing a mass Exodus out of
Washington to Tennessee all right well
let's address the school issue because
this is the default for most people well
do I go get a degree so I can make more
money and I'm not sure that you can
afford to go to school do you guys have
any debt at all um $10,000 in the car
okay okay how much in the car car um 10
10 the 10 is in the car I thought you
said 10,000 and the car debt free I mean
de on the car sorry hey let me ask you
this Caleb okay um you guys are
23 Ken
um in my mind I started thinking about a
new baby coming and I got a little bit
panicked if I'm him I got to go make
some money like this just got real this
adult thing and uh and I'm going to be
in a state that's unfamiliar I'm making
a move after the and with a brand new
two-month old three-month old baby at
that point yeah um I would first
probably if it's me I'm just going to go
figure out a way to make the most money
in the shortest period of time first
then second I'm going to try to figure
out the what I'm supposed to do longterm
and move towards that yeah that's where
I was going with all these questions you
need to get settled and settled is I got
to be making
$75,000 uh you know or change our life
and so we get in Tennessee get in the
zip code we get a job or two jobs my
friend or three or three to take care of
mama and baby and we want to again not
go backwards financially to be honest
with you this cost of living is going to
be way less anywhere in Tennessee I
would guess than most places in
Washington do your homework on cost of
living don't just make a move because
well the brother and sister-in-law are
moving so we're going to go and if I and
I'll just be honest with you I wouldn't
move right away if I couldn't move right
away I'll move to Tennessee when I can
move to Tennessee and the can is
determined by the job yeah we'll have
about 22,000 in savings by the time that
we move so we'll be pretty set we're
going to be rent um saving 1500 a
month I thought I I must have
misunderstood your
income okay you're making combined 75
correct yeah so we're making about 5,000
a month and we're
putting yeah so we're putting about Well
here here's the thing here's what I want
you to do I want you to take some of
that 22,000 and I want you to buy uh a
couple of round trip tickets to the area
in Tennessee that you're going to be in
and I want you to come come down and get
a job go get a job get a job lined up or
two lined up or three lined up right to
where you step into 75,000 with a
reduced cost of living it's a net gain
for you day one here and then yes take
Ken Coleman's materials I'll give you a
copy of his book uh from paycheck to
purpose and let's figure out what your
purposes I'll put let me go ahead and
give you the assessment get clear get
the clear get clear work assessment
that'll help you figure out Direction
but again uh please don't step into more
money more time which is schooling let's
get a job get settled get stable get
baby here and then determine Direction
and then figure out the plan to get to
where you want to go that's exactly
right Dave right now it's too much too
many moving Parts he's young there's
time but let's be smart about this so
the the the thing
Caleb and others we want you to hear is
knowledge is important but knowledge
that takes you to where you want to go
in your career is vital sometimes that
means going back to school a lot of
times it doesn't vaguely in air quotes
go back to school as the solution to
every income problem seldom works that's
correct don't do that that's like
escapism you're escaping reality I'm
going to go hide on the college campus
and not have to deal with the fact that
I don't know what the flip I'm doing
that's right it's like signing up for
basketball camp if you want to go to the
NBA one does not guarantee the other and
so we've got to be smart about this oh
that's that's harsh that's harsh right
there I'm dealing with the reality this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a 100 if you run a business
with different software systems that
don't talk to each other that's why
there's netw Suite by Oracle in the
early days of Ramsay we were using
different systems for all of our
business units we needed one single
source for accurate data netw Suite was
the software we used to optimize and
take us to the next level netsuite gave
us the visibility into all of our
numbers so that that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for ramsy and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34,000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com
Ramsey that's netsuite.com
SL
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramsey Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is
our our co-host today I'm your host Dave
Ramsey the phone number is
8825 5225 Andrews in Salem Oregon hi
Andrew welcome to the Ramsey Show hey
Dave how are you better than I deserve
what's up that's hey I have a I want
some advice you know I'm a 23y old 23y
old uh family of four uh my wife is a
stayhome mom I have two little kids and
uh I have some money say I've been
saving for the last you know six years
and I I work a full-time job I make
about you know a little under $100,000 a
year and uh I'm on the track to even
grow some more and we're just my wife's
going to college this this winter and
it's fully paid for we don't have any
debt but we really want we're really
anxious to get into a house but we want
to know if it's a good idea to you know
go and look for a house now or if we
should just wait until my wife is out of
school and start our looking B
so when she's out of school would she go
to work using the degree and in increase
the family income yes ma'am yes yes sir
okay right so that would change the
equation on that would change the
equation on what house she would buy
based on her new income when out of
school so would it it sounds to me like
I'm going to wait till she's out of
school cuz I can get a different
house yeah uh I guess yeah cuz she's
going to be a dental a hygienist so her
school is all paid for I we just I'm
talking about I'm talking about how much
you want to spend on a house would
change if you had more income correct
yes yes so I probably want her income in
the equation before I pick out a house
house okay and I mean we we just have
this lump of cash we're just sitting on
I mean we have it in investment accounts
and stuff but what what would be a um a
better solution on making more I'll just
sit on it just just make sure it's in a
high yield savings because you're going
to use it in within two years
dude yeah yeah you don't you don't want
play with this money because you might
lose
it we want just sit there let's let that
golden egg let it let it
hatch okay yeah put it in a good high Yi
a good high yield savings right now
paying five I mean you can get that
but um you know but you're not going to
get uh uh I mean you don't need to be be
trying
to yeah let the the main goal is get a
house when she gets a job and we don't
want to mess that goal up by putting
this money at risk yeah there's a
Temptation uh Andrew to feel like I'm
wasting my money by renting every month
and I'm not getting any Roi on this and
that's just simply not the case here and
I think what you're going to have to do
here is switch your mindset set from
that to I'm going to get a better House
have a much better down payment with
patience and so put your mindset on that
patience is not throwing money away
patience is having more options better
options yeah you're
you're yeah you're you're going to forgo
a little bit of something now in order
to get a bigger something later that's
right it's a delayed pleasure thing yeah
very good Nick is with us in Leck Texas
hi Nick welcome to the Ramsey
Show good there da Dave how are you
doing better than I deserve how can I
help good to hear so I'm a sophomore in
college currently 20 years old I am
currently on an academic full ride so I
don't have to worry about paying for
college debt which is nice and I work
two part-time jobs bringing about 1,600
a month I'm just trying to wonder what I
should do as far as saving for the
future I want to put it I have the
Thousand emergency fund and just kind of
want to see what the next steps are and
what yall think I should do since I'm
kind of young and it's a little bit of a
non-traditional format for people
usually at my age yeah agreed it's not
really a baby step thing what are you
studying I'm studying pre-law and
philosophy I want to go pursue be a
lawyer uh hopefully an appell at lawyer
then future judge okay and so you need a
lot of
money yes sir that's that's why I got to
start early yeah so um we're not doing
anything except stacking cash are
we yes sir that's the plan I'm I have
two savings accounts I have the
emergency plan and then I have one that
I'm just stacking cash in yeah try to
pay for law
school you know the fact that you got
free college with academics way to go
also says you got a great brain and
that's going to help you get into law
school good way to go um fits right in
with your goals I love I love what
you're doing so what I'm going to do is
just do everything I can to pay cash for
law school yeah and to that end uh
what's your GPA right now Nick 4.0 see
uh I want to let you know about
something and and you can go check me on
this I interviewed a lawyer from the
Houston Texas area has written a small
book on this on my show several years
ago and here's what people don't know
with your GPA and your intelligence if
you get a great LSAT scorer there will
be law schools all across the country
Nick that will give you a full ride to
get a law degree but it may not be a
name brand school it just depends but
don't just get sucked into this big time
law school that looks great has a shiny
you know bells and whistles all over in
the brand name be aware that you at your
intelligence level an elet score can get
a free ride for law school nobody cares
by the way where you went to law school
so I'm going to point that out a lot of
law students don't know that Dave
because they think it's about the name
brand yeah I I met with um two attorneys
outside councel on on a deal this
morning and our Council our in-house
counsil all three lawyers I know where
our guy graduated from cuz I hired himh
but other than that I have no idea where
the other two graduate from and let me
just tell you they were brilliant
they're brilliant I mean the strategy
and stuff we came up with it was like o
this is going to be fun and why did you
hire them if you didn't know where they
went to law school I don't care where
they went I I hired them because I found
out who they were and the results they
had gotten in the type of a thing I'm
hiring them to do they know what the
flip they're doing and I I don't really
care where they went to law school
they're brilliant I do know just in
conversation that one of the guys' dad
was a law professor at Miss
right but other than that I don't know I
don't know where he went yeah isn't that
fun so yeah that's the deal so um
yeah I've hired a bunch of lawyers in my
life I have no idea where any of them
went to school uh I've hired a bunch of
docks and I went going I got a physical
they have no idea where my doc went see
the reason that this exists Dave is
because law schools there's a lot of
smaller law schools out there are just
you know not as big brain uh excuse me
brand names but they want sharp men and
women like Nick so they'll give them a
full r so that they can say Nick went to
our place yeah so go go yeah and then he
becomes an appellant and and then a
judge you know I mean there you go doing
appeals so yeah that's um Nick do do
research that out and so our
recommendation is I don't care where you
went to school if you get to go free and
you get a free law degree to go with
your free undergrad U there's a
philosophy of life Mr philosopher that
you could live with right there I'm just
saying way to go man very cool very cool
you're smart stack the cash pay cash and
or get a free ride to school that's the
game plan and nothing more than that you
don't need to do anything else job one
is get Nick through this without damage
and debt yeah that's job one and because
Nick you are the best investment that
you can make yeah I mean mathematically
getting the law degree is the best and
and paying cash for it is the best
investment that you can make you are a
bet you can't put money in a mutual fund
get that kind of return you can't put
money in real estate get that kind of
return you you know knowledge that is
usable in the marketplace is the best
return on investment mathematically yeah
here's a question for everybody watching
and listening that may be wanting to go
to the path of Nick imagine billing
hours right out of law school that you
can save and invest not pay debt off
with imagine just imagine that idea and
it's all about kick and tail on the
elsat and that's the
bridge wow is that true on the MCAT too
I don't know about the MCAT I only know
on the elsat because interviewed a guy
who just you know yeah who did it okay
wow and by the way you can take the LSAT
as much as you want now you got to pay
every time but that won't break you if
you're going cash so the point is this
is does it run an aggregate score or no
it's just like much like an ACT SAT the
the last time you a super score like act
I don't know that is but there is a
level and I'd have to look it up by
which you score over and law schools
start going bananas with offers I love
it love it well there you go boys and
girls you going to school hm that's
it what we've lied to people in America
we told them degrees matter and where
you get them from matters neither one
matters what matters is knowledge yeah
not getting knowledge is really bad go
get knowledge but it doesn't necessarily
have to have a degree and it sure
doesn't need to have a famous name
beside it this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by the their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
40% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsey
Solutions on the debt free stage Weston
and halier with us hey guys how are you
we're great Dave how are you better than
we deserve than we deserve how are you
where do you where do you guys live we
live in North L Rock Arkansas all right
and how much debt have you paid off
89,90 dangerously like 90k way to go way
to go how long did this take it took 3
years good and your range of income
during that time we started at
$113,000 a year and we ended at
$139,000 excellent what do you guys do
for a living I'm a registered nurse in
cancer research I'm a healthcare
recruiter all right all right did you
recruit her no he tried just recently
not professionally but you know I was
going to say only with a diamond ring
yeah just in high school I may have
recruited her a little bit a little bit
I love it way to go very cool what kind
of debt was the 90k oh it was there so I
have I have the story for you okay okay
so was my birthday weekend we're at the
lake with our financed boat our financed
camper finan truck we only owed 700 on
the on the truck um but yeah so we had
boat camper student loan I think our
couch was financed vet bills uh I mean
we had everything um but the dog the
dogs in pretty much everything yeah
pretty much
everything and what happened oh but yeah
so um a friend of mine called I'm a car
I love cars and so a friend of mine
called and uh at the time we only owed
$700 on their truck and he called me and
he said hey do you still want a Cadillac
CTSV and I'm like well of course I still
want a CTSV
and he like well who wouldn't right yeah
and I was like well I can't afford one
he's like oh yeah you can so it was a
good deal so I had to I had to try to
prompt her and I on his birthday on my
birthday so it played in my favorite did
he stick his little lip out did my
birthday I did I came and I was like
look deal of a sentury all right let me
just figure this out so what did I do I
refinance the truck to pay for the CTS
fee of course and then a month later I
got laid off so then we had all this
stuff going on yeah we can make these
payments oh wait maybe not on my
birthday he got laid off there's a lot
of bad birth Vibe here right right
before Christmas too y'all need to stay
away from birthdays so that was kind of
the okay we we need to calm down a
little bit yeah yeah and then how'd you
find us I was actually looking at after
he got laid off trying to figure out
ways that we could save money so I had a
list of all of our bills laid out and I
just kind of thought oh my God if we
didn't have all this debt we could live
on one income and we would be just fine
so then old Google I start looking at
paying off debt and then Dave Ramsey
comes across and I love podcast so I
picked up the podcast and once he um got
employed and we got income coming in we
we started all up in February and we
were good to go after that just like
that just like that we three years later
we're free yep amazing thank goodness
got a paid got a paid for CTS now no oh
so that's the funny so one thing I was
going to tell people is that the coolest
experience is so the CTSV is paid off
and ever since then we've had two new
cars for her but we've only come out of
pocket $600 cuz you just trade straight
across with we got a van instead of a
CTSV now we had another child we had
another baby during this whole process
so you went from cool to minivan you
made the transition it's the the man van
thead life life van life baby I might
rev it once in a while with the
stoplight that's all right that's it
Rachel Cruz bought a van because she's
got a house full of kids and she spent
most of Thanksgiving that year trying to
convince us she was cool yeah well see I
used to hate Vans and then we actually
had a loner van and I was like this is
actually pretty cool they are it's a
very cool car it's just funny to hear
people try to convince you it's cool it
is it is it's great way to go guys I'm
proud of you thank you yeah by the way
it's not cool but it's it's functional
let's let's just keep it real let's not
dup future buyers in
hey look it has a
screen seats I avoided it that's why I
can say that all right so here's what I
want to know so you start listen to the
podcast this is cool because you know
Dave's been doing this for a long time
and now we're hearing things like hey we
didn't pick up a book we picked up the
podcast I'm curious as you were
listening to the show whether it be
other debt-free screamers or just calls
was there a moment where it really
clicked for both of you to we went okay
we it's game on time man I think that we
heard several debt-free screams that
just really resonated with us and we
were like that's that's us that's our
family exactly if they can do it what's
stopping us you know we can do it we did
both read the book though I will say
after we started on the podcast okay you
got you got got started with the podcast
the book gave you the detail that's the
yeah there's Money Makeover Total Money
Makeover but yeah hearing those people
just like us doing that debt-free scream
it was it was kind of a light bulb
moment that we can do it too and I
listen you know every episode and
especially when you get people in our
age group that have like paid for houses
and stuff I'm like why didn't I start
earlier you but you're not Tau that
stuff when you're younger you're it's
like you know go buy what you want and
have a great time but now you now you've
proven you can make this money thing
behave and you'll be a do anything you
want to do now ex it's a whole different
world what do y'all tell people the key
to getting out of debt is um I tell
people to have a a partner that holds
you
accountable no more car no more car
deals no more car no more birthday yeah
yeah really for Budget yeah budget it's
the budget I remember our first budget
we did we looked and we were spending
$600 a month on eating out and you you
didn't know cuz you're like H seven
bucks here seven bucks there MH and then
you know $600 later you're like H and
and I'd say communication too um there
were some times during especially
through the student loans at the end
where um things weren't going so good we
were really getting burnt out and I mean
we had a $7 over budget just allout
argument when he knew there was no money
in the budget but he went ahead and
spent
$7 and you would have thought that it
was the end of all things I threw a a
Manchild moment that you say I was like
I'm tired of being on a budget I'm going
to spend this $7 but you know and then I
came home with my toe between my legs I
was like but it was communicating you
know when we're struggling together and
saying hey I'm struggling in this you
know and let the other person kind of
help and then there were times that the
other one struggled and we just
supported each other amen amen and then
through it your whole relationship grow
stronger confidence confidence in each
other and in the future get stronger for
sure hope you know there's we can really
that we're going to be okay I don't we
going to be okay we're going to prosper
you know I mean really very well done
good for you guys
congratulations we're so proud of you
Heroes you took control of your life man
you wait on somebody else to do it you
went and did it yeah excellent excellent
hey we've got the live and give box for
you it's got the baby steps millionaires
book for you Total Money Makeover book
for you to give to somebody else since
you've already got one and have read it
and the Financial Peace University
membership as well so I will give all
that to you thank you for coming all the
way over from Arkansas you want to bring
the kiddos in for the debt free scream
what are their names and ages this is
Jackson he's six and this is Taylor and
she's about to be two in December all
right so H how's she do when her mother
screams about stuff
we don't know
yet get
ready I love it she might not be happy
all right Weston and Haley Jackson and
little Taylor from Little Rock Arkansas
$90,000 paid off in three years making
$13 to 139 count it down let's hear a
debt-free Scream 3 2 1 we're
de didn't phaser that's awesome I love
it very cool very cool James how many
debt-free screams do we have on the
YouTube channel now that people can
access it's got to be thousands right oh
yeah I mean we have all they're in all
our full episodes so every day but don't
we have a don't we have a you can just
watch those or you have to go watch the
episodes we don't have them posted
separately now oh I thought they were
separate okay so there's thousands
literally okay and you just flip through
and you find one because the social
proof is there what they were saying is
so important folks you know that there's
someone like you MH exactly like you
that's done a dead free scream we've
done too many thousands of them that it
isn't and that's what he means see when
you see someone that that's well if
those people did it then that says to
you you can do it right and that tells
you and that's why we continue to do the
debt free screams number one number two
to honor Heroes like these who have
taken control of their lives but you
guys there's a massive catalog of ramsy
on YouTube uh be sure and check it out
uh now we're up over a
1.5 billion downloads with a B on
YouTube alone this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based nonprofit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living AC across all 50 states so see if
chm could be right for your family check
out more today at chministries.org SL
[Music]
budget
[Applause]
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
hey guys if you've been listening to the
show and you're enjoying it we could use
your
help uh literally I mean really we need
your help it changes everything if you
will
subscribe on YouTube or follow or
whatever the method is on whichever
podcast platform you're on um or just
tell people about the radio station
you're listening to whatever it is let
people know and a lot of people have
like a share button on some of the
things and you just click it and you
send it to three friends and go hey
check this podcast out check this
YouTube guy out these people over here
are making a difference they're helping
people leave a five-star review that
helps do the likes and that kind of
stuff that helps anything that helps the
algorithm on those particular platforms
put push our show forward we know a
bunch of you are sharing and subscribing
and following because we see your
numbers number one but number two we see
our rankings going up in every one of
these platforms so thank you for helping
us with that doesn't cost you a thing
and it's a way that um uh you know we're
not going to spend like $300
million on a football stadium to tell
you we're here like s or something like
that excuse me I got allergies but the
um but yeah you don't want to do that
and so uh we're not do that we we we
we're not like that so but you guys are
our biggest Champions to help us move
this thing forward we need to create a
crusade in America and have a
Renaissance in The
Art of Living
Well having the right career the right
mental
health the right ways of handling your
money I mean we the people can do better
we don't need someone else to tell us
how but you hey we'll lead the charge if
you'll help us it's that simple uh Cara
is with us in Indianapolis hi Cara how
are you I'm doing well how about
yourself better than I deserve how can
we
help I uh currently have a job that
works great for my family it's a good
income um I'm just not passionate about
it I've only been there um about four
months and historically I stay with my
job a long time um I was just offered my
dream job this morning um and I am
nervous about discussing that transition
with my current employer because I
haven't been there very long so how do I
go about that well first of all
congratulations on getting offered your
dream job that's not let's not just
Cruise past that how did that come
about well I have a history in uh cardio
thoracic surgical ICU nursing and I'm
now a a nurse practitioner and so I uh
heard about the opening with the surgeon
uh that I used to work with through a
friend and I reached out and they were
really excited that I reached out and uh
what will you be making at the new
job um uh 120 and what do you make
now uh 122 okay is there but I'm
guessing there's room for growth here
with this new
job yeah yeah um every year they're
they're pretty consistent with making
sure that they uh compensate you well
yeah okay well first of all
congratulations So my answer to this is
always the same and it's really simple I
want you to put yourself in your boss's
position and I want you to in your mind
you just kind of roll play that out how
would you want you to come say Hey
listen I've only been here four months
uh but I got a past relationship with
this surgeon an opportunity was there I
reached out it's my dream gig uh I I'm
sorry to put you in this Lurch and and
do this at this point four months in but
this is an opportunity that I have to
take I mean that's your reasoning you
don't have to explain that away but how
would you say that in a way that is
humble uh filled with gratitude
certainly sensitive to the fact that hey
you're leaving only four months in but
you don't owe them a certain amount of
time what you owe them is your best and
I don't think you'd ever be able to give
them your best if this if you turn this
opportunity down and so if you have that
mindset how would you want someone to
handle it with you that's the best way
to go cuz I know you're a person of
character and a person of class did they
pay you anything or pay moving expenses
or a signing bonus or anything when you
took this current
job uh no it's um a better schedule for
my family and and the one you're in
today oh what we're saying is are there
any strings attached the four the four
month old job do you have anything you
owe them because they paid for you to
move or they gave you a signing bonus
and now you're going to take the signing
bonus and
run nope okay all right so you just took
a job didn't cost them anything and um
okay yeah I I I'm with Ken I think you
just be sensitive to uh how would you
want to be treated if you were them if
I'm them I'm disappointed but this great
lady is going to go she got something
that she likes better she's going to go
do it there's not a lot I can do about
it so I'm going to be classy about it
and say well certainly understand um
you're going to are we going to do a
twoe notice or what are we going to do
here and um you know just be honorable
and kind and tell the truth and just be
you know I think you say out loud I'm
sorry I did not take this job intending
to do this I this fell in my lap and
it's something I've always wanted to do
and I'm going to take it uh but it I do
feel bad about the way this worked out
and I'm sorry yeah I do okay I just
wanted to was there a more professional
way to say that but that sounds
compassionate and professional so well
sometimes profession gets in the way of
people stuff and and I love the way Dave
said that I think he gave you a great
perspective from the leader perspective
just be a good person and you are a good
person that's why you called there's a
sense of guilt I get this call a lot on
the Ken Coleman show Dave and people
feel guilty because they're good people
but if you're not doing anything
ethically wrong uh and you're not doing
anything illegal then guilt shouldn't
enter the equation so understand you
understand as a human that has good
relational skills that you've greatly
inconvenienced someone and actually cost
them money that is correct because you
you could you know when we put somebody
on at Ramsey it cost us quite a bit of
money to on board somebody you know and
then turn around 90 days later they're
gone it's a it's a net loss for us
that's correct but I also don't want
them to stay here if they have their
dream job that's right I I on on on the
further down the line though I don't
want to be as an employer used you know
I'm going to take this job and then keep
looking correct and all over the place
anything if I can get 10 cents more I'm
going to jump no no that's that is a
lack in ethics I agree then job Hoppers
are very different than that's not hoing
that's just speculating I mean it's like
right it's uh yeah that that's a that's
wrong ethically but that's not what car
is doing no no so good job Oakley's with
us in Cleveland Ohio hi Oakley welcome
to the Ramsey
Show hey thank you so much Dave for
having me on I appreciate you guys sure
how can we help hey so I just wanted uh
some insight and wisdom from you guys on
how a young couple like my wife and I
could best uh attack the debt that we
have uh become debt free with the
situation that we're in uh and and
ultimately pay off again everything that
we have how much debt do you have not
counting your
house uh about a little under 50,000
okay and what do you guys
make uh collectively about 115 120 okay
and so if you lived on 70 and made 120
that'd be 50 not counting taxes you'd be
out of debt in a year you follow
me yep we got to count taxes so you're
not going to make it in a year but
that's the math yeah that's the math you
got a good siiz shovel and a mediumsized
hole this is very doable now what do we
do we get on a written Budget on every
dollar and go to everydollar.com and
sign up for/ budgeting and sign up for
one of our free webinars on how to use
the budgeting app to get things under
control and you and your wife sit down
you stop all investing you take any
money you've got that's not in
retirement and you throw it at this debt
we're going to list the debts smallest
to largest we're going to attack them
with a great intensity a great Vengeance
like like paint yourself blue and wear a
kilt right I mean you're getting after
it you know what I'm saying and so you
knock it in the head you knock it in the
head you knock it in the head we're not
doing we're not going on vacation we're
not eating out we're going to take our
lifestyle down to scorched Earth and
we're going to live on less than 70,000
so we can pay off 50 with a 120 income
in around a year and you can do that
what's your smallest
debt uh it would be my uh actually it
would be my student loans about five
grand okay yeah and so you're going to
have that done in uh a little over a
month boom one done and you just keep
doing it just keep doing it keep hitting
it keep hitting it keep hitting it keep
hitting it and that's the process so
jump on every.com budgeting and sign up
for Cruz Jade warshaw or uh George camel
doing a webinar for free and get
yourself into that every doll app and
get this thing going you can do this
it's called the death snowball list them
smallest to largest and attack them in
that
[Music]
order Dave here you can find all of our
shows with the Ramsey Network app on
your smartphone it's the only place to
listen to the entire back catalog of
episodes download the Ramsey Network app
in your favorite app store
[Music]
today live from the headquarters of
ramsy solutions it's the ramsy show
where we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships I'm
Dave Ramsey your host Ken Coleman Ramsey
personality is my co-host open phones
atle
5225 thanks for joining us we're glad
you're here Sarah is in Jacksonville
Florida hi Sarah how are you good how
are you Dave and Ken thanks so much for
taking my call sure what's up
all right so my husband and I uh built a
house about three years ago and the
equity um the value of it has really
went up and we have about 625,000 in
equity right now and we're just really
on the fence if we should sell in
downsize and um probably get a little
bit older of a home and um pay for cash
and have no mortgage and we just can't
seem to to get there we want to we know
it's the thing we should do why should
you do I'm not sure you should do it you
don't think we should do it or you don't
know I don't know I guess it's just had
the no the no mortgage just what's
what's the house worth uh it's probably
worth a million okay what's your
household income about 200,000 okay it's
not out of
line so how much is your mortgage what's
your mortgage balance what's your
balance uh 373 okay you got other
Investments that are not
retirement I do um and we could probably
pay about 60% % of it off with our
non-retirement
money so like 200,000 of the 300 yeah
probably yep and then you got a $200,000
income and you knock off $100,000 worth
of
mortgage yeah I guess so I think that's
what you're going to
do okay okay like you're going to be
debt-free housing everything in 24
months okay okay the thing is we we we
put an offer on a property about a month
ago and we said if they take it's meant
to be and and they said no because we
came in low um and they just came back
to us two days ago and said are we still
interested and so it's just uh no cuz
you're only moving down here because
you're having some kind of
emotional like uh shame or like like
we're we're afraid to do good I mean
what why are you afraid to have a nice
house I don't know I don't know because
I live I live amongst people 25 years
older than me and I think I probably
should go to a different
neighborhood I don't know because you
mean just because you don't feel like
you've earned the right to be there yeah
you make $200,000 a year you earned the
right okay all right I mean I don't I
don't hear anything you're doing wrong
if you don't like the house I don't care
if you move down but it feels like
you're moving because you feel like I
mean there's almost like a shame in your
language
yeah I guess I just feel like uh you
know we could get I don't know live life
faster I guess maybe we're we're down to
our third kid he's a freshman in high
school we got three years to go we've
already gotten two out of the house and
do you want that house when the when
you're an empty
nester yeah I think it would be fine any
house I live in I'm fine with I we've
live Eight houses it's not it's not like
it's some kind of super I mean it's a
nice house for a million dollars in
Jacksonville Florida but it's not like
it's a $2 million house I mean you know
it it there's a lot of million dollar
houses in Jacksonville Florida they're
all over the place you know I mean right
what do you mean by you started to give
us something what do you mean by live
life a little
faster I don't know I think for so long
we had kids young at age 20 and um and
we've just been working hard our whole
life and it just feels like if we just
not have any debt maybe we won't have to
always be thinking about what we should
be doing all right that's it okay so so
this is when you get out of debt it
doesn't give you a pass on thinking
right I know but I actually think you
don't the idea of you going hard at
paying off this house uh is a little
exhausting to you it feels to me like
you just want to downshift because you
just want to slow your effort and pace
and you just want to chill it doesn't
seem like you want the house that you
would be moving to it's like you want
what you think that house is going to
give your pace is that closer to what's
going on uh 100% yeah okay so that's
that's that's a little different animal
and I'm not sure again that you need to
sell this this house to get that that's
what I would push you on no I I would
say I'd say 24 months you're going to
have that in this house I think so too
using your mutual funds and your income
to knock the mortgage out that's what I
would do yeah Karen is in New York hi
Karen welcome to the Ramsey show hi Dave
hi Ken hey what's up my question is I
started late with listening to Dave
Ramsey a year ago and now I'm
66 I only have about
$180,000 in my retirement and I have two
houses I'm still paying for which will
be paid off in the next five years and
my main objective with money at this
point is to have something to leave for
my kids so will it be
a better investment for me to invest in
term life insurance so they get a
tax-free payoff or will it be better for
me to invest in the mutual funds when
I'm not sure how much compound interest
I'll be able to accumulate in who knows
how much longer I'll live you know
insurance insurance is not an investment
it's an
expense you don't make a return on
insurance the insurance company makes a
return on it and so no you
no you don't buy term life insurance to
create an estate no you don't buy life
insurance of any kind to create an
estate that's not the purpose of life
insurance so don't do that take what
money you have and let's get these
houses paid off as soon as possible and
let and let's build this Nest Egg some
more so in seven years your 200,000 your
180,000 will be 400,000 if you don't add
anything to it if you've got it in good
mutual funds it'll double every seven
years okay so I called you yeah so at 73
you'd have 400,000 in there if you don't
add anything to it and you're going to
have the paid for properties and the
properties are worth
what 400,000 each okay so 800,000 plus
400,000 so a million to how many kids
have you got four okay so they're gonna
get three or 400,000 bucks a piece if
you live to your mid
70s I know really why do I want to do
this why don't I want to spend money on
myself but I appreciate you guys so much
you me because I always make ridiculous
money decisions no I think you've made
some pretty good ones you're doing
pretty good you're doing better than you
feel like you're doing I think um yeah I
think you're going to be able to live in
inheritance with the Investments that
you haven't used I also do want you to
enjoy some of those Investments um and
you know cuz that you're under no moral
obligation to leave an inheritance
you're not a bad mom if you spend all
this money and then die you're not a bad
mom at all matter of fact you're like
the party mom if you did
that the fun Mom Mom Mom Mom's going
everywhere look at mom look at what Mom
did now that's cool uh yeah because
you've worked your tail off your whole
life and you've done a good job you're
not hungry well done this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
Ken Coleman ramsy personality is my
co-host today our question of the day is
brought to you by neighborly your hub
for home Services fall means football
haha and changing colors but it doesn't
mean the time for lawn care is over
neighborly is your source for experts
like Grounds Guys and Lawn Pride
download the neighborly app today and
find the trusted Pros in your area great
company neighborly today's question
comes from Gabby in Washington I'm a
recent graduate with a bachelor's degree
in Health and Human Services I love
serving my community and I'm currently
with a nonprofit the problem is I make
about $2,000 a month and have student
loan debt of about
55,000 I have come to the realization
that while I love working for nonprofits
it is not going to help me pay off this
debt I really do not want to go back to
school but I would love to move into a
higher paying field should I apply to
these higher paying jobs even if all
even if I only have about 40 to 50% of
the qualification I would love any extra
words of wisdom well that's a tricky
question because there's a lot of
evidence on both sides of the aisle one
side being a lot of companies will put
out all these qualifications but if
you're a good candidate that they feel
that they can train you and that you've
got the core of what they want they'll
hire you and then there's the other
school of thought that you'll never get
through the online application system if
you don't uh lie about the
qualifications so my take on this is I I
like to meet in the middle I think if
you've got the Core Qualifications
you've got the uh chuch put to go after
it uh and you can use the connections
you have I wrote a book called The
Proximity principle that's what you need
and so if I can make connections I know
somebody that knows somebody that knows
somebody could be three four levels it
could be a direct connection to these
organizations that have a higher paying
jobs I'm going to go about it that way
and I'm going to get around the AI
application software and I'm going to
give it a shot I have nothing to lose
I'm certainly going to do that Gabby
before I think about going back to
school and again if a degree is the only
way or the best way way to get
requalified in this case if you knew a
different direction then yes but we want
you to cash flow it um that's the only
option that we tell people for school so
just going back to get a degree that I
can't afford get into debt to hope to
get another job is not the best way to
go about it so I would take that
background the education you have now in
Health and Human Services it's a lot
broader than you realize then use the
proximity principle and go about it that
way and I think you can get there yeah I
think you can get around the lack of
qualifications if you get to humans
that's correct you get your resume out
of the stack and get it past the AI
screener into the hands of a human so a
guy that I met with three years ago sent
me an email this morning his daughter's
roommate okay this is like my cousin's
Uncle sister's ant I was keeping track
yeah okay daughter's roommate of your
friend of a guy I met with three years
ago yeah an acquaintance I have not
talked to him in three years okay I I
like this even better okay okay sent me
an email this morning and said my
daughter's roommate has applied at ramsy
oh can you can you help me with her
resume and I'm like absolutely
not I can forward it to HR to Armando
Lopez our director of HR and I will
promise you that they will look at it
but that's that's all I cuz I don't do
hiring here I haven't in in 15 years and
um but I I but you know what her
resume from an Uncle's aunt's cousins
brother's sister's roommate got into the
hands of the director of
HR and he sees it and he's going to look
at it thousands of applications a month
that's correct that he never sees right
when her application came in the first
time right he never saw it right but now
it's he's does that mean she's going to
get hired no no but you did help but did
she but I put it I put it in front of
someone that can decide now right so
then no PR
that's correct but she's like
98% ahead of everybody else oh yeah to
at least get a look no question you know
you get a look and then it's up to you
once you get the look and so that's the
proximity principle that's exactly right
it's exactly how what you teach and
teach people to do you you did did I
look at her qualifications no I don't
even know what she was applying
for so but will they look at her
qualifications yeah when they interview
her for a certain position they
certainly will and then will they look
at her character and will they look at
all the things that we look at at Ramsey
before we hire someone it's very
difficult to get to go to work here uh
because we only hire thoroughbreds we
try to keep the donkeys out of the
building can't win the Kentucky Derby
with a donkey that's right you can get
hired at the CIA a little faster than
you can here yeah yeah and I don't like
I don't like working with crazy so we've
got all these crazy screens to keep the
crazy people out I don't want them I
don't want to pay crazy people that's
crazy so we want to do that so anyway
got all this stuff and so she'll have to
go through every bit of that but you
know what she's way ahead of where she
was 24 hours ago when she was in the
stack with everybody else without
question that's the proximity principle
and that's how you work around I don't
know if I have the qualifications do you
have the personality do you have the
character can you get the job done do
you have the initiative are you hungry
humble smart as our friend Pat linion
says are you are you going to be an
ideal team player that's the title of
his book and you know you're going to do
these things and then if you got if you
can convince the hiring manager of that
ding ding all of a sudden the
qualifications unless you just simply
are incompetent to do the job don't
matter as much y That's right there you
go open phones at 8825
5225 Rashad is with us in Baltimore hi
Rashad how are
you hey guys thank you so much for
taking my call Dave and Ken thank you
sure what's
up so me and and my wife are a bit at a
bit of a Crossroads with each other and
I'm hoping for some wisdom from you guys
each I know with uh with each other when
it comes yeah with each other when it
comes to uh our side hustle so we're
currently at on baby step number two
where we are attempting to pay off our
debts uh so that we can eventually save
up for our house and our emergency fund
okay um but at this stage we are kind of
hitting a wall with each other because
she keeps talking about our side hustle
she keeps talking about doing something
called Amazon uh selling products on
Amazon and you know she keeps talking
about like in buying a house so that we
can eventually invest in real estate
which I know you've done so I'm just
hoping for some guidance because I I'm
honestly at a loss and I'm actually a
little
terrified uh about losing whatever
little money that we actually do have
right
now okay Amazon Drop Shipping you should
not have to invest any
money is she proposing you invest money
into that
Venture well it's not really it's
basically like how should I put it in
what she what she does is she'll go out
to like department stores and look for
deals on certain products and then sell
it for a no it's just selling at a
higher price yeah that's not Drop
Shipping she's just flipping that's all
she's flipping product so she's going to
tie money up in
inventory correct yes yeah I'll pass
yep yeah so I mean like so for me it's
like I work full-time I have a full-time
job which brings us money and then I
have a part-time job that brings us
money and I'd rather go to my part-time
job that actually brings me money rather
than sit over there and figure out this
this stuff you know figure out try to
try to find products and I feel like
that's just a waste of time I can
actually devote that same amount of time
to going to work and actually bringing
in a a fixed amount of money a fixed
income and I don't know how to talk to
her about that I don't know how to make
her understand like I feel like that's a
waste of time oh I think you've said
that it just didn't get
through right you told her that exact
thing didn't
you yes I didn't go well had several
arguments had several arguments about it
no you got a messaging issue I I'll just
quickly say this that you know the waste
of time we've already shot that bullet
and so we need to start talking about
emotion that you have the risk of tying
up money uh come at it that way a little
bit more logical with some real emotion
instead of calling what she thinks is
cool a waste yeah it it's um I can't
this terrifies me cuz I see us losing
money instead of making money that's
different than you're stupid and this is
a waste of time
so it scares me because I don't think
it's going to work and it bother and I
don't know I don't know how to talk to
you about this because I you don't seem
to see any risk with it but you could
buy a bunch of stuff and it sits in our
garage and that that scares me I don't
want to do that uh cuz I'm trying to
work so hard to get out of debt here um
if we had some extra money we wanted to
try that that'd be different but right
now we're
broke this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of Ramsay
Solutions on the debt free stage Ty and
lah are with us hey guys how are you
good how are you good how you doing
better than we deserve welcome good to
have you guys where do you live Amarillo
Texas all right bit of a haul over to
Nashville just a little bit yeah good to
have you guys how much debt have you
paid off
$582,000 good goodness how long did this
take we started in
2013 uh and then just finished up here
like I think it was in July or August so
10 years 10 years years yeah wow and
your range of income during that decade
uh it was anywhere from 65,000 to 114 I
me we sold some houses and I sold a
business in the midst of that too so it
kind of had some variation there too but
gotcha okay but that was my W2 income
what you what what do you guys do for a
living now uh I actually work for the
Department of energy but before this
I've always Trad Commodities or Trad
some type of feed so but I just didn't
like that and actually I read Ken
Coleman's book and decided to take take
a change in life really how's that
working out love it good it's a great
we're on a we're on a we're on the 13th
day of our road trip to get here just to
have a vacation and Dollywood and
everything come see you guys yeah come
see you guys wow there you go fiveyear
plan of a trip right here there we go
lah what do you do I'm a stay home mom
and we have four kids going on five wow
congratulations well done all right what
kind of debt was the 582,000 oh we had
it all
uh some of it was just I I farmed and
run cattle so I had a lot of farm debt
um I had a house uh a $50,000 Duramax
Man Zero interest they'll do it every
day of the week for you um wow had a I
had a Nissan car um and we had our house
it was about 235,000 uh Tiffany's rings
for this young lady that was you know
they finance that too don't worry
yeah I had about two $20,000 worth a
student loan that she paid for cuz she
saved money before we got married so uh
she came into a mess before she decided
to take me on uh and then yeah I had
some some Farm debts and stuff like that
and then some uh I also took even a
$5,000 trading class to learn how to
trade Commodities but or trade futures
or online come to find out you can't
trade unless you have money so yeah it's
kind of a show it's kind of table Stak
to tell her yeah yeah she tried to tell
me that was I'm going to claim that
one's one of my stupid taxs right there
I don't I don't have any money cuz I
just spend it all on the class that I
tells me I need to have money yeah I was
kind of sitting there about halfway
through it thinking man I this is dumb I
think there's something on my shoe yeah
I think I stepped in it yeah wow good
for you man that's so cool yeah so you
went from player to cleaning up the mess
cuz everything you said there was like I
do everything man oh yeah like boom and
now you're just like like Bo straight
and narrow yeah it really what drove me
onto this deal is um I for when I first
came out of college I bought cattle for
a major Paco company I spent a lot of
time Western Kansas and there was only
AM radio over there there was Dave
Ramsey uh I was focused on the family
and Rush limbal that was my there was my
theology in life and I every day I'm
just spending time riding around looking
at cattle and listening to you and I've
basically that started in 2006 and never
stopped wow wow well thank you we
appreciate you being out there yeah good
stuff okay so who decides 10 years ago
we're actually going to do this stuff
well we we started off trying to kind of
cheated a little bit because some people
say I'm cheap I like to say Frugal but
um when I saw the price of the envelopes
I was like we don't need the envelopes
we'll just kind of do it you know and so
after about a year of that and we were
still fighting about money um we decided
we need to take this seriously um you
know if it's not broke don't fix it so
we went ahead and kind of got the um we
lived out in the country so we just got
the at home study program and watched
through that together natural University
at home yeah bought the envelopes
started doing the Cash System set up our
budget um we had to do that budget
meeting you know every month sitting
down together and kind of getting that
going um so that was kind of the hard
part at first but then once we got the
ball rolling um we found other things to
fight about but we didn't find about
money anymore so um it just it kind of
made everything organized we knew what
to expect of each each other and where
we were at and it just kind of went from
there and like you say it's just that
boring consistency you just do the same
thing over and over and then you see it
make progress and it gets really
exciting yeah there you go and for her
it just it was a security thing like I
mean that was one thing that I noticed
that really uh she just that was the
rough part for her even for me I mean
growing up as a kid I mean my parents
they're they're good people but we just
we had some financial problems growing
up we had bankruptcy and man that just
that I don't want that for my kids yeah
and I want them to know that what we've
done as a sacrifice as a as a couple
yeah now you're free yeah yeah you're
free you when you talk about the grass
feeling different there's some truth to
that yeah there is a lot of Truth to and
and that's one of the I mean I don't
know if we we actually before we got our
debt paid off we passed the millionaire
mark and it was just like I don't know I
just I still don't believe it I I kept
looking at the spreadsheet because I was
a spreadsheet before before you had the
every dollar app and and kept looking
I'm like that can't be possible but it
just a lot of dedication and a lot of
time and that was probably the hardest
part for me well decade in you're 100%
dead free and baby St millionaire yeah
and we just we that was the consistency
like there'd be some times where you're
just like man I when does this end and
but there was if you saw it on the
paperwork you knew it eventually was
coming to an end I want you to talk
about that stay right there because
there's a lot of people that are in the
middle of their journey and there we
know they're watching and listening and
they they're feeling it today they're
going I I don't know finish yeah
what did you do or what would you tell
how' you keep going what' you tell them
well you know honestly that one that was
I'll bring our faith into that one I
mean God was good to us even I'll admit
when we were we we made the least amount
of money we made the most because we
were the best with it at that time you
know More Money More Problems type
scenario and that's probably where we
were as a group you know as me and her
and and even the Lord and our life
that's where we really we had to Bunker
down and just be tough and not go you
know forget about it we're just going to
go on vacation we just didn't do that
kind of stuff you know you just have to
stay strong and it comes wi out yeah it
didn't wig out yeah I think we both got
to the point where you you realize you
make a mess of your life you know and
that really God's the only one that can
fix it so it's great to have a program
and it has great principles in it but if
you don't have god um at the center
where you can take your mess to him um
then the principles only get you so far
and so God really was Central to our
story um and got us through a lot of the
hard things that we went through amen
amen well and it it you know when you're
a person of faith and you're leaning
into that and you realize the system I'm
using has the principles from his word
in the system then that tells you also
I'm going to be okay yeah you know I I
got reassurance from that when Sharon
and I were walking that out you know
it's like okay I get it that some of you
people don't understand but I don't care
this is what Dad says to do and Dad's
really smart that my heavenly father and
sometimes even what he says doesn't make
sense and you don't understand it I just
have to assume he's smarter than me
exactly I'm going to go with it cuz I'm
I'm not doing so good on my own so yeah
he's smarter than me I know that I'm
sure of that yeah I've never made a
world so I'm pretty sure he's smarter
than me that that whole that whole you
know the the uh debtor is slave to the
lender and that is I mean I took my
first loan out was with the USDA when I
was 9 years old on some cattle and so I
wrote my life away at 9 years old and I
knew nothing else until me and her got
married yeah and now the other day your
baby steps millionaire is not a debt in
the world yeah Amen on that one I will
tell you what not to do cuz you talk
about some people are the nerd and and
some are the the fun Spenders well he's
definitely more of the nerd and so he
he's a spreadsheet guy like you said um
but he would make his spreadsheet and he
would bring it to bed and be all excited
like look at this we got to have some
boundaries here yes you're romantic aren
don't bring theie to bed and show me
we'll talk about that over coffee in the
morning I'm thinking I don't want to see
the spreadsheet now could be wrong oh
gosh
wow yeah that's nerdy for so he's
definitely the
nerd I love you guys you're fun well
done hey we've got a copy of the baby
steps millionaires book cuz that's you
Total Money Makeover book cuz that's you
and Financial Peace University cuz
that's you you can give those away you
can read them whatever you want to do
they're your our gift to you bring the
kiddos up and let's have a debt free
screen what are their names and ages we
have Adeline which is our oldest and
she's 10 we have August that's seven uh
and then we have Piper she's five and
then we have Dax and he's fixing to be
two in November and then number number
five will be born in March love it
582,000 paid in 10 years make it 65 to
114 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream you guys ready three 2 2 1
where're
yeah that's how they do it now Mill boys
and girls woo I love
[Applause]
[Music]
it
our scripture of the day Exodus 28
and9 6 days you shall labor and do all
your work but the seventh day is a
Sabbath to the Lord your God Robert
Frost said by working Faithfully eight
hours a day you may may eventually get
to be the boss and work 12 hours a
day isn't that true oh my gosh that's
the truth Ken Coleman Ramsey personality
is my co-host today we're glad you're
with us America thanks for hanging out
Drew is in San Antonio hi Drew welcome
to the Ramsey Show hey thank you for
taking my call Dave and Ken I'm really
excited to talk to you my question is I
recently got laid off from a major techn
ol company uh actually located in Austin
a Semiconductor Company and I'm kind of
having a hard time with a career change
do I still kind of go with the kind of
the tech sales where I excel really well
I've been applying for jobs and not
getting a lot of like um responses back
and I'm just really kind of I need like
a clear pathway so I'm really excited to
talk to can about this about what should
I do with my career and should I go like
get like another you know another
certificate like in cyber security I
know you were talking about code school
one time just want to get your thoughts
on it please well so do you want to go
into cyber security or coding of any
type or is this just more of a well I
feel like I need another option what's
the want to behind
this uh it's the other option sir if you
could snap your fingers and do anything
what is it
yeah I can snap my fingers do anything
I I really want to my own tech company
i' I've had the experience for the last
15 years your own tech company what's
the tech company
do uh it'd probably a financial
technology app that would be able to
help not similar to every dollar but
just help people manage their money in a
more efficient way and so you've been in
Tech sales the last 15 years yes sir
okay uh so in your mind what's the best
path forward to get to that place is
there some experience you're still
needing or is it about capital or
both both okay so I'd be I'd be I'd be
charting my path in tech for the
experience that I would need to leverage
one day for my own company so that's
what I would be thinking about so is
that that's not cyber security yeah is
that cyber cyber security is a complete
sidebar to everything you're talking
about right uh yeah yeah you just pick
cyber security because there's really
stinking good money in it that's right
yes sir you're right Dave yeah so so
here's the deal you need to be moving
forward in the type of tech work that
one day you're going to understand well
enough to hire people who can do it and
develop it so it's all about experience
so take it back my journey I wanted to
get into broadcasting so I had to
actually start doing small broadcasting
gigs this a different deal you can get
paid full-time for this so you've got to
get in that lane that is going to
prepare you to run your own company one
day and quite frankly you need the best
financial opportunity because you're
going to be stacking cash for years so
that you can launch this company and do
it the right way without any kind of
risk other than just the cash that you
saved so what direction is that what is
that Tech
Direction it would have to for me
to be able to as you guys say be on a
Sho string budget code the app and as
you would say Dave launch this on your c
table in your house making sure it's
cash flow system not going into debt by
any means necessary yeah but what's the
what is the dire is it coding do you
need to become a programmer and really
good at
it yes I would need to code part of this
then that's the direction so now back to
your initial question so you don't have
to go to a four-year school to get this
to get the the actual qualifications uh
we matter of fact it's the longest route
it's the longest route so we actually
work with bethl tech they train internal
folks for us I endorse them they have a
$155,000 program for Ramsey Show and Ken
Coleman show listeners contact them have
them walk you through the program and
it's a 9-month online program so you
shouldn't do any Interruption of income
if you need to get a job right now so go
get hired and and get some stability
then sign up cash flow through a program
like a bethl tech and then within nine
months you're qualified and ready to go
we have stories of people that are
starting out making $80,000 have gone
from making 45 to 80 and so you can get
on a nice track be making six figures in
2 years and now you're on the path to
funding your future so you don't need to
go to fouryear school here and we're
giving you one option to kick the tires
with uh but that's what the path looks
like for you but right now you need to
get hired and you just applying applying
applying doesn't seem to be working I'm
going to give you my book The Proximity
principle you know dial in on your
relationships and let's get a good job
that will take care of you now and then
allow you to pay for this next level of
certification yeah that's exactly the
route to go and uh but in the meantime
it sounds to me like your current skill
set is sales yes and you can make some
really good money in and around the tech
World in Austin Texas San Antonio Texas
in sales around Tech all kinds of
different sales and all kinds of
different tech for that matter so uh and
that's a way to put uh food on the plate
while you're executing on your small
business launch idea yes and learning
your code yes all that stuff so
beautiful beautiful well done Robert is
in Grand Forks North North Dakota hi
Robert welcome to the Ramsey
Show hello hi what's
up he I've got um I'm not in any um
super dire predicaments I'm just kind of
trying to make a better life for my
family in the future here I've
got um I've got some debt on my vehicles
right now um I've got a debt on a
fourwheeler loan that I bought last year
um and my house
loan it's really kind of kicking me in
the butt here how can we
help um so my vehicle loans I have total
up to about including the fourwh about
$122,000
MH um I am the single income bringer
into my family my wife and my daughter
what's your
income um I make uh 32 before taxes
every month 3200 okay what what do you
want to
do um I I was curious do you think it
would be smart
to uh pay off my vehicle my vehicle you
have the
money um I have about
$155,000 complete in savings between my
wife and I m so that would leave us
about $3,000
to take care of our house payments um
take care of our kid and so forth well
you work you take care of your house
payment and your kid with
that yeah you're not using savings to do
that you're using your income to do that
right um it's kind of it's kind of
digging in right now because my my house
payment just went up 100 bucks and soed
my insurance yeah but you got car
payments and four-wheeler payments yeah
yeah so Robert this will work if you use
the money and pay this debt off and then
you get on a budget and you quit
borrowing money for stupid stuff like
four-wheelers yeah that's that's kind of
what I'm thinking right now it was it
was a good idea at the time to no it was
not a good idea at the time you did not
have the money you're broke and you have
a baby and you make 32,000 there's no
four-wheeler in
that matter of fact you may need to sell
it but um aside from that yeah so here's
the thing if you'll get on a budget and
you and your wife say we're going to get
out of debt not just just to get out of
debt so that we take our income and
build up a nice emergency fund back to
15,000 so that we can start investing so
that I can advance my career and make
more money so that we can build an
emergency or we can build a college fund
for our kids so that we can pay off the
house so that we can become very wealthy
outrageously generous and change our
whole family tree if that is what you do
after you pay off all this debt then
fine if you pay off all this debt and
then just keep doing life the way you've
been doing it well that probably wasn't
very good advice on my
part but I want you to play all the way
through my man this just starts the
journey it's not the end of the journey
the reason we get out of debt is so that
you change your family
tree and um you you start figuring out
how I can make more money start figuring
out how we can save and invest more
money how we can be more generous you
start figuring out how Investments work
and you change their whole whole way of
looking at this
world that if that Journey Begins with
paying off the debt let's do it Ken
colan good show today thank you sir that
puts us our the Ramsey Show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ
[Music]
Jesus hey it's Ken if you like what you
heard in this episode and want to know
more about getting started on the ramsy
baby steps go to ramsy solutions.com and
click on the get started button we'll
help you figure out the best next step
for you based on your specific situation
again that's ramsy solutions.com and
click get
[Music]
started